[Music]
well hello everyone good evening hey
Carlos Tracy back there Sarah good to
see you s shut up the best intro ever
best intro ever okay so I know what I
know the keywords now uh good good to
see you
all everyone online with us it's going
to be a defrosting evening here in St
Louis it's freezing here I I'm sure if
the if the if the uh if the lecture was
going to be 2 hours I I would have I
would freeze something I mean I I would
get I would get attached and glued to
something someone says El is preparing
oh that's you okay so uh I want to talk
about pwn pushes Palm braks so break
from the
freezing freezing everywhere it is
freezing yes it is freezing not not
where I come from North Carolina weather
is just
fantastic well for that one reason I
miss
home all right so I will talk a little
bit about um Pawn pushes Pawn storm all
of
that blizzards of Pawns do I have to
explain why I don't wear a hat anymore
or no B we're good people are very upset
that you're not wearing a hat how upset
they are on on scale 1 through 10 it's
it's getting bad it's really bad without
the Hat well I was told you should lose
the Hat it look better without the hat
so unless you want to do a poll on that
maybe sure huh we do do we do a poll on
the should I wear a hat or should I wear
a hat yeah shall I just leave that to
denish maybe no no no I mean I mean
there's lots of good hats and chests but
uh let's get to the bottom of this and
see what people prefer okay you can
actually can run yes okay good should
wear a hat or not
okay
well people say I have I have a nice
hair why should I wear a hat then it's
good
huh we we'll give it some time to get
some results all right so this is a
game Sher of pgar and then the next one
is also Sher of pgar and I just happen
to like these two games because there's
a lot of Pawn interesting Pawn pushes in
them so E4 C5 Knight F3 D6 D4 C takes D4
Knight takes D4 Knight F6 Knight
C3 I don't know if it's a it starts with
E6 or A6 nowadays nobody does E6 anymore
E6 and uh if I put E6 on the board I
mean CU PA play E6 right but if I put E6
on the board and where is my what do you
guys do with the with the with the leous
engine here why do you guys disable
leous engine here anyways it will show
plus one G4 and the attack is just
crushing
yes yes G G4 and just it it gives plus
one it's killer and okay let's say A6
Bishop E2 E6 still G4 G5 is but okay
this is how they played and uh car you
know from 1985 match you also know from
car Kasparov match that Kasparov uh
Kasparov employed shingan system and was
very successful and won the game 24
against karpov and Kasparov became world
champion so it was going through all 90s
on until that this English attack became
a thing and then people started to
switch to E5 and then E6 became a
whole semi obsolete kind of an archaic
way of playing but still it's playable
in certain positions it's
playable um you know it's very funny A6
is considered bad like for example
A6 here
here like for example like this this was
shown by tall many years ago that
actually what has a crushing attack here
or for example early Knight B d7s like
some people do night and this this T had
shown like in his games that this is
just you go long Castle G4 G5 and kills
whenever B5 Bishop B5 buam
done so yeah tall that that was
uh that man knew how to play
chess so uh let's keep going with with
whatever is the I think the
game was uh A6
F4 Queen C7 and then G4 right
away right way
so I people said put on the hat well I
don't have a hat with me so sorry it's
in the thumbnail it's in the thumbnail
okay the
thumbnail all
right so
G4 uh and then Rook E8 was played in the
game makes sense do you know are are you
familiar with this idea Carlos do you
know about this idea or not why does r
rookie doing I don't okay so I'm asking
people online what does Rookie do it's
known as a payi maneuver have you do you
know that name pki pvi was four time
Soviet champion and he was one of the
Pioneers in Sicilian Defense all modern
ideas we know about Sicilian comes from
pki actually the very
first uh Encyclopedia of Sicilian was is
written by
payi good
okay fantastic so why well people say
bip of a well du yes I want to go B of A
well what's the idea behind it so in in
those days Pol figured out that after
this G5 F5 to be solid well go figure
solid
um and the idea is that if I go G5 and
then say I go this move and I want to do
this attack uhhuh I have enough time to
do this this uh this and Knight f8 and
then I can counter in this
side and that's how Caro played it uhhuh
so The Rook is also to reinforce if they
go F5 you go Bishop
f8 who what his name again guys
povi L payi when people say who it just
wrenches my
heart Lev
payi Lev payi he's like the
how to put
it he's like panar in chess I should
have he's a mathematician Panara
okay he's a Panara of
Chess is the foundation of modern Theory
comes from him if you buy kasparov's
book on 70s chess Revolution all the
things coming along he has a very good
uh no nobody offended him people say if
they offended him no nobody offended me
I'm just I'm just exaggerating
my I'm
just what what Ben Ben Simon
what what no you're just very offensive
I'm very offensive offensive person can
I go defense a little bit huh do you
think I can go defense a little bit
huh I have to try I have to try I'm I'm
being too offensive I'm offended you're
offended how offended are you been I'm
going on Twitter right now you're going
on Twitter yeah I'm going to what's your
handle again tell me what's your handle
too because I have to ban you tell me
just right away I'm going that offensive
I'm going that
offensive bring it y all right so
anyways this is the idea so here here's
the point in In This Moment uh should
have play
F5 so I am putting the normal normal
pressure but this is a trick question
this is not a trick question this is a
trick move so you would just say okay he
wants he's attacking on E6 so I have to
go Bishop f8 right mhm that's the that's
the natural move that comes in mind but
the natural move is actually D5 this is
the best move you have to counter white
has overextended too much and the center
is semiopen and quite Dynamic so you
have to take an action right in the
center so the D D5 strike was the right
one because if I go Bishop f8 as he did
in the game as she did in the game G5
and this is what Fisher has had cooked
up for for pogar for anyone who would
play this against him
F takes
E6 now guys if Rook d8 loses to this
huh now Rook E7 F E6 we don't have Rook
E6 because of is F7 check so and if this
this and Knight D5 is coming and it's
crashing uhhuh everyone's good caros
good
fantastic no no sorry people just I'm
just being sarcastic or I try Okay
Bishop H5 G6 take Rook E7 all right how
does white continue this
attack s do you like the topic of the
day is it good good so SAR likes it good
people I hope people like it too I hope
it's defrosting
enough
I'm going to give people time to ask me
questions here this is a very
interesting
position Queen F3 goes Bishop G she will
go Bishop G7 then Knight E5 Knight C6
and uh I need two Mo queen Queen d8
Bishop G7 I'm
good
Bishop D4 is a better move but I still
go KN
E5
Rook F7 that's that's a powerful move
but it's again Knight Knight
D5 can I play Knight D5 that's the
that's the plan yeah Knight D5 Knight
D5 Knight takes
D5 Queen takes D5 King here and now
what
how is the poll coming up Ben Simon it's
very interesting I'll share the results
is it are the results skewed into a
direction or
no I mean there's only two directions I
don't know well I I I I mean ski is like
10 1090 like or 2080 something like that
no it's competitive it's competitive
interesting
good
Daria and and it's important to note
that you're literally the only person
who can't
see I'm who can't or who can't you in
the chatter all the Chatters know you
can't see I can't see it okay some
people say funny some my an interview
from me from of me from Olympia probably
10 years ago it's because I I was at the
Olympia
2014 so it had somebody had gotten a
recommendation that watching my my
interview from 2014
I I was wearing a hat in 2014 yes and I
was talking about Sherlock Holmes
so yeah she's saying that yeah I was
wearing a hat yeah we need dark squares
sorup says well we wish to have the dark
squares but I don't think that's the
point so the power of threat it's time
to strike and we're talking pawns so G
takes
H7 Rook takes H7 Bishop G6 and funny
enough like for this things like this
doesn't work because I go Bishop G4
that's all Frozen and this is it's hard
it's impossible to defend against
this
mhm and I cannot do things like this
because I mean I think I can just do
this
right so um she played this move this
she play Knight E5 but after this is
just game over I mean we're not even
down material and the attack is just
decisive so
Sheriff uh play a trick and won the
game we do talk about the pawns yes yes
so yes this was the trick so play F5
like if it doesn't matter because the
main line in those days I think there
was a game of stovsky G5 Knight here
Bishop D3 this was the Tavia of this
position that people were playing so sh
have played F5 like oh it's going to be
this this the story with the I'm
attacking the pawn I'm preparing G5 so
she played this move G5 here and now
she's she's prepared against the move F6
but she just didn't know about Knight
takes C6 at the time came as a surprise
I remember when was this game played I
don't have the let me see
the oh you check the you check the
game yeah yeah you just ah you just
checked it huh yeah okay sneaky
sneaky sneaky b yes 96 yeah it was very
it was very
uh I read actually the I read actually
the article things were coming to you on
so late with such a lag I read this in
'98 I read this in '98 the article it
was translating
fary
so but
then but then pgar had a palm break
uh revenge and I think poar had the
overall lifetime positive score against
sherff I'm not so sure but I think
against shiru she had a positive
score so okay this is
before it's
94 all right E4
C5 Knight F3
E6 so I don't know if this is one of
those tournaments but I
remember whether it was Miguel nider
himself or a friend of his who who was a
millionaire they were both in Insurance
business and you know the story of life
story of Migel nid so you know the name
of course but you know where he was from
so you know where nid was from actually
originally Carlos do you know where
nidor was from Miguel nidor yeah where
was he
from nid I believe so yeah where was
where was he from ah not Hungarian so
this is good point people say
Argentinian he immigrated to Argentina
but he was originally from Poland he was
a he was a Jewish pole so he was in
Argentina in 1939 during the chess olymp
and then the war triggered the War Began
and uh he being a Jew and and the
invasion of Poland by the by the Nazis
he stayed in Argentina started his own
business and everything so years later
when the the opening named after him n
and then he was lifetime Sicilian player
although I have to tell you guys I know
he losses in Sicilian against tall so
I'm not that big I'm not that big on
actually his wins there but he is known
for his Sicilian so he he had this
themed tournament E for C5 Knight F3 uh
where he uh had it for a few years and
uh yeah it's uh it might be that
tournament I'm not so sure though so C
takes D4 Knight takes D4 and Knight C6
Knight
C3 and and she played D6 but now we know
that this is a bad move in this system
F4 Bishop E3 Queen F3 is just crushing
if you play like this against this
system setup and the most recent game
that I can show as a classical example
of this is ivanchuk against van Val Ben
are you gonna search ivanchuk Van
Val Ian one with white pieces
so in the 2000s at least 2010s this is
considered really bad Bishop E3 F4 Queen
F3 we know from tall's time that this is
really bad because I have zero
flexibility to exert any pressure on
White Center and white just go F4 que3
G4 G5
and collapses but this is 1994 so
luckily for pulgar uh it's it's okay but
uh actually should have had an idea
should have started with G4 so he knows
that if he stor starts a pawn storm it's
going to be better much better for white
but uh here PA guard did something smart
after A6 Bishop E3 she didn't put the
Knight on F6 she played Knight E7 which
is still bad but it's better than Knight
F6 in my opinion practically speaking
she play Knight E7 what's the idea she
wants to take on D4 and place other
Knight on C6 correct everyone's on board
with that then s you're on board he's on
board too
perfect so um so this is the threat so
now we have a concept of super fluous
Square that's a $20 wor for a very
simple concept and super fluous square
is that I have this a square this is
square C6 for a knight but I have two
knights to go there mhm so when white
plays Knight Knight B3 very strong move
now I have two knights but I have one
square super fluous Square how do you
spell super fluous then s p e r l o us
us us always always always
us
yes so and Knight B3
B5
F4 Bishop B7 Queen F3 so uh and J still
gives very good vage to White in this
position uh but it's more complex now
now here I like the way
uh let's see okay black to
move and I really like what what what
Paul guard did
here and if you want to know uh sorry
it's one of the if we were to rank the
top 20 games played by all female
players in the history this is probably
top five it's very really nice game
completely out classes
shff somebody has already seen it
bummer give everyone about 3
minutes you have an idea sah not
yet take your time Carlos do you have an
idea not yet okay take your
time goes long Castle D5 they opping the
game for your
opponent
Queen
C2 you mean queen C5 C7 sorry Queen C7
C7 sorry it's a normal move it's it's
okay yeah uh you're going to have to be
careful after Castle there is Bishop
takes P5 hello welcome to the
chat okay it's about pawns right the the
class is about
pawns yeah don't resist it that's the
move yeah G5 it's G5 yes it's G5 G5
actually came like was the first thing I
thought about and I
was yep we want a square so G5 F takes
G5 Knight E5 Queen
G2 B4 Knight E2 now
what I love this move engine hates it
but I love this move the way the way
pgar plays in this game is so
entertaining to
me try again guys
try hello welcome
A5 not too slow too slow come on we need
some we need some skin to the
game you still got it wrong okay don't
like A5 no A5 too slow
what don't resist it say well what if
it's bad I mean apparently it is bad but
H5 H5 yes is what she play but it's a
bad move yeah the thing is after G takes
H5 she played Knight F5
yeah and after Bishop
F2 it's
amazing the thing is I think here G
takes H6 and it doesn't work as much but
you go Knight here Bishop here you have
a lot of counter play Knight G6 Knight
H4 but I think he just has long just
just has long
Castle but okay H5 G takes H5 Knight oh
okay actually G takes H6 maybe we have
F5 here here so yeah the three Pawn
pushes isn't it beautiful it's very cute
it's very
cute and then G takes F5 maybe I can
take with the Knight again now yeah and
then wow anyways that's that's amazing
three Pawn pushes G5 H5 F5 I think I
think we would love to see this one how
can I not see the Tracy do you know how
I can see the engine analysis because I
don't know the eval in this position I
cannot do anything
put
the what this thing yeah it doesn't have
anything for me I don't know
why it is the clubs stud what's that are
you not the owner of Stud I'm afraid
we're not probably we are added to some
study by Ralph or
not yeah I think he owns the
study whatever
okay so I think I think we have a five
Carlos and then after capture Knight
captures Bishop here I think we have a
lot of things engine has lost it I mean
even Bishop even Knight H4 is good
because I can pick up these two pawns
then this is hanging this is hanging
it's just like return on
investment so well let's look at the
game G takes
H5 Knight Knight F5 Bishop F2 and now
what do we do here uh this is
beautiful
okay abat found
it now C Castle Queen takes G5 because
if Queen takes G5 I go check here and
then I will win this pawn and I'll win
this pawn and then I'll kick this rook
and I'll win this Pawn and we're just
smashing completely
winning yes F5 is still not hanging so
played Queen G5 to Knight A5 and now
it's the winning
move pgar performance is amazing this
game I love it I love this
game here deliver is
amazing
Castle takes on
B7 it's asking you
guys
I don't know how
to so what move again Bishop Bishop H
six
um the problem is I take this guy you go
check he I mean or you take this
Bishop's hanging that's the problem
that's the
problem
so the movies because I want to show
some more content so is Knight E3 isn't
it gorgeous that's what I was well say
it because Queen G5 mate is mate so and
if and if take on E3 Queen takes E3 and
now this cheick is coming without any
you
know any def any any plausible defense
against it winning material and this is
gu hanging as well too so she played
this
move and he played Queen G3 check check
King
D1 um Queen G3 KN
G3 Knight A1 Knight B7 B3 and get the
Knight out p you see this easy yes but
you first have to see it on your own and
B3 and the Knight comes out and
then the the players were in time
pressure her uh both players play s part
but what black is winning and she
converted once she was winning in a good
style we don't care about that part but
gorgeous games huh I really like the
fact that this is all pawn pushes like
if you go back to this moment G5 H5 and
if and if and if he had played G takes
H6 F5 that would have been really nice
to see three pawn p PES but you know
Pawn pushes for
me pawn pushes for
me always means
blockade and breaking the
blockade and
uh I am going to show you a classic
of this
dilemma where is
my file here here is the
file so K of
goric Zurich
1953 s have you heard of Zurich
yeah no it's one of the very first
tournaments that professional chess
actually in a Modern Way have been
approached the way half the fil Soviets
there's a famous book about it written
by
bronstein brunin and
uh he explains Al not he explains but
also they wrote a lot about it that how
all the Soviet players had a second you
know coach who would help them with the
adjor games uh I don't know if anybody
knows about ad Jordan games but I mean
not not you I people who are in the
chats I'm explaining G Jord you have
people you analy but then you don't have
an engine at that
time what I someone in the chat asked we
were in a parking lot kind of look like
we're at a parking lot
H
well well if we continue at this at this
rate I think I may end up in a parking
lot soon it's about as cold as the
parking
lot yeah well thanks for the word of
encouragement really thank you so yeah
so so it was talking about and kotov and
all of these guys who play in this
candidate tournament that how they had a
coach they would go in the morning they
they would go for a walk then they would
go uh to swim then another activity and
then another activity so the Soviet
authorities wanted to make sure that at
least one so player would qualify in
this tournament and how they had like
the regimens the foods they were eating
the everything was portioned control
everything and uh now is we know in top
at that at the highest level it's it's
really important matter in in every
sense so and the book has really um the
writing is is is is quite gripping and
uh it's quite interesting but um I
really don't like the analysis so I was
too strong when I started reading the
book I was
probably uh strong I am level for a guy
who is for early 2000
2201 so I couldn't enjoy the analysis
because I could see mistakes in the
analysis I was strong enough to see that
uh but
the rioting is the way he explains
things and the ideas is very interesting
so people see love so this is a game
between Alexander kotov and switar
no switar
goric you know you know goric from from
um Kings Indian was was an expert on
Kings Indian and kotov the famous book I
think like a
Grandmaster so kotov play D4 Knight F6
C4 G6 goric plays his system you know in
those days they they had beliefs they
had the system of beliefs that this is
working actually so for example if if
gor had already lost three games in this
opening he wouldn't quit it this is a
very interesting thing nowadays people
would just quit an opening in two games
ah this is not good this is bad and he
would just come back and try to prove
his concept doesn't matter which
position he would finish in the
tournament it would matter that he shows
his concept is correct my Kings in then
stands it's a correct opening
different different mindset very
romantic so D6
F3 uh this is zish system cast and zish
is already not only in Kings Indian
anything Al in nimzo with F3 is a zish
system so guys if you go D4 Knight F6 C4
is this is also called zish system
anything with F3 in in all the D4
opening are considered zish so zish is
play German player uh fr zish
he's he he his concept was I want to
occupy the center right away so this
very the setback is that the Knight is
bad I'm weakening the king but he's uh
he he is trying to get the center right
away so let's get to the main line so
F3
um where am I uh Castle Bishop
E3 well you call it cool you've seen
that famous game of KP of Kasparov where
carens up with all his pieces on the
back rank uh after 21 moves have you
seen that
game good content for tomorrow or maybe
on
Thursday uh Bishop E3 E5 now is
considered inaccurate actually this move
not that inaccurate but is not correct
and this is definitely bad this is Def
now is this this is definitely bad
people say show
it so someone says fish s his concept
was Anno Ben final because he's obvious
says don't play F3 I think been final
right is that true his concept was never
play
F3 freddish demish versus Ben fold
always play F3 always play F3 always
play F3 okay so uh Bishop E3 uh E5 D5 C5
Bishop D3 Knight
H5 uh Knight Knight G2 uh Knight and and
pawn F5 and after Pawn F5 um we take of
course I can't I can't even go Queen D2
F4 Bishop
F2 and uh it's very fun if Ben would say
don't play F3 and he's a king he was a
king Zena player for a long time himself
Ben fine gold so this is a perfectly
playable position with with white and
with this idea of playing A3 and uh
B4 so e takes F5 G takes F5 and white
played Queen
C2 all right now now I really love what
what gor did and guys think about it gor
probably never analyzed this position
happens at the board he doesn't get
increment on his
moves he's sitting there against kotov
first time seeing this position and he
comes up with this deep
concept people keep asking me about the
growth the growth of artificial
intelligence I'm really worried
about the demise of act actual
intelligence because it's we're going
down on that
so I'm not worried about artif
artificial intelligence guys but the
demise of no not 86 no
no not that it has to be E4 yes it has
to be E4 E4 F6 E4 F4 I get this
beautiful Outpost over
here and Bishop F2 KN
D7 and come
on Alex kotov you got to go E5 I don't
know how he didn't go E5 he went he went
Knight G1 no dude cannot do that I'm
sorry can't I can't I I don't buy this
queen G5 now he's under
attack kotov is really counting on on on
um breaking the blockade
so Queen G5 Bishop F1 Knight
E5 uh Knight F3 now where do I put this
queen
so always undevelop your pce is that a
ban fungle thing also or not always UND
develop your piece something you'd say
something you would
say well I like
Ben Ben is a good
man not this
Ben now this man is cool too I dig your
style queen7 is what he play in the
game Queen
H6 so I'm going to make it concise well
he did he I'm going to continue on Queen
H7 but queen6 is the move just for the
sake of brav we just say castle and then
Knight
G3 and that's why this move is very
strong Queen H6 was a
stronger well people said that was a big
M yes this is there's there a Big Mo but
there's no coffee in it it's it's only
tea I don't drink coffee at this time so
Queen E7 was
played uh Knight takes E5 uh Queen uh
yes Queen takes E5 Castle Knight
F6 but this is a waste of time
actually A6 B5 is the move to go so why
he play Knight F6 Sarah he wants to go
Knight D7 Knight D5 but it's a little
bit it's a ttis slow he had to go A6 B5
right
away so um after A6 okay he didn't play
A6 played Knight F6
H3 and uh Bishop D7 I don't dig this
move to A6 again must must go for it so
Bishop
D7 Bishop D3
A6 and how do we stop this queen now
here
uh C play very strong move Knight B1 the
idea is to go to to this to score and
kick this queen the position is balanced
it's not a big deal uh if if he had
played Bishop E8 Bishop H5 to control
the square and play Knight D7 but
uh goric got too excited here
guys got too happy what did he what do
you think he
did no he didn't play
B5 one which F3 yeah he play F3 well
it's a gorgeous blockade it's very
nimian like AR nimzovich but number one
two guys in this world despise n of
theory the number one is yasan and
number
two and NS of which his block his
blocket his idea on blocket is too
extreme in my in my in my opinion
although I I shouldn't say like that I
don't despise I just it's sometimes it's
too simplistic it's too
uh
uh uh too extreme in a sense to believe
it's like a belief instead of a instead
of a concept so G takes F3 so this block
hit doesn't work because he always has
his Rook G1 so Knight H5 Knight
D2
um yeah this mean here for example is
the first win white missed do you want
to try to find it white why to play and
obtains a seemingly winning position
seemingly just
better
yep some God Bishop be
won okay so he didn't play that he
played
uh people seem to like it with the beard
as well to the beard wasn't in the
question though the beard is in the
question good Ric H ridiculous the beard
is ridiculous no no the concept of
asking
is what the hat or not hat yes why you
you consider ridiculous huh there got to
be two separate po you can't be grouping
all these items together in one po it's
going to be confusing and it's not there
should be four groups it's 2 by two now
no beers hat no beer with beer and hat
no beers no hat should we wait until the
end of the hour to uh call the poll or
do you want to call it now no I mean let
me wrap it up five minutes and then we
can do the okay yeah 92
okay uh
Knight D2 Knight F4 Bishop
F1 uh B5
H4 okay here is not playing extremely
slow why is playing too slow after
Bishop uh B5 B5 H4 King h8 Rook G1 now
he wants to do something like this we
don't want to give up the bishop at all
at any cost so we go Bishop F6 also
covering this a square as well uh G5 so
plays the move uh White plays the
move what does he
play
what plays Knight
B3 yeah okay I mean they are not Saints
right so they can
blunder I mean makes no sense to me I
actually pay didn't pay attention to
what what an absurd move is this maybe
planning to play this way maybe it's not
that bad of a move
it ah okay maybe there are Saints
uh yeah night A5 is the plan
so yeah
wow yes it's got I got him I got it some
people say bc4 Knight A5 yeah I see the
plan now now Knight D4 is too much CD4
and then you give up too much too many
many pieces for for one Queen so that
Knight D4 is not a plan here yeah for a
second I did not understand what Knight
B3 is
doing so
um so Bishop to uh he plays Rook a B8
makes sense and then Bishop E1 wants to
go to C3 I got to go B4 and now he looks
good and
then
Knight A5 was the better move there and
then King
B1 and then Rook eight is a bad move I
don't know yeah these guys are probably
in time pressure they just played
thematic moves yeah not now Knight A5 I
mean that's just that's just a bad move
that's just a really bad
move here Rook G8 is the right move and
I said and I put a note to myself
um black shifting to the other side with
and also Bishop A4 is a plan to maintain
the uh to maintain the blockade this I
call this a super blockade because now
you have two two blockades next to each
other
um so
um Bishop G3 he played Rook he play Rook
A8 Bishop G3 I said Knight A5 is better
Queen D2 or Bishop G3 ah here there's a
mistake here guys there's a there's a
mistake here Bishop G3 is a mistake
because I have Rook G8 Rook takes
G3 uh yes I think this was balanced but
no no this is not balance here Queen D2
wins because I am threatening Bishop G3
in the game he played Bishop G3 first is
a mistake he played this this and then I
have or he played Queen H2 I think in
the game doesn't matter either way I
take and play Knight D3 so here he
played this and after Rook takes G3 Rook
takes wait a second this this yes Knight
Knight E2 because Bishop B2 is mate so
he has to take with the queen because he
has to defend the sky and queen G3 and
now this bishop is a complete uh it's a
it's a full compensation is a full
compensation now this bishop on F6 and
this pieces are passive I don't have F4
E5 I really need to move like F4 E5 D E5
F5 I make a blocket on e4 that's as far
as white has to go if he wants to
climate Advantage
here yes so yeah kot of missed the
win
um so Queen E2 Queen takes
G3 Knight C1
A5 Knight D3 obviously E5 is coming so I
have to play Bishop D4 H5 Queen H4 I
don't know what he's chasing on he's
chasing the pawn and then there's no F4
because of Bishop
G4 uh Queen
H4 Bishop G2
Rook
G8 Rook H1 Queen
G3 Bishop
F1
A4 King C2 A3
B3 and funny they agree to a drop which
is minus one for
black this is minus one for black
guys um but the how part is a little bit
hard to understand to
Fathom yeah it's it's
just well it is kind of on uh goric
because they passed the time control and
when they pass the time control they
would take their dinner break and they
would go to analyze the game and he had
all the time to make that decision and
he took a draw for here they they he
took a draw here
what no play for white yeah that's
understandable but how do you actually
out play is very interesting here and
the interesting part begins here with a
move Rook f8 Bishop G2 and then you kind
of put in a zuk with a very interesting
move for black I'm going to just do this
a little bit how do you put in a sort of
a
zong the Knight looks good actually
just
well whenever I see these games with
this all many mistakes and like what
what what they are doing I'll look at my
my losses and then I realize that we're
all
human uh so the funny thing is
that now I mean Bishop C is kind of the
type of move but you wanted this to guy
at some point to go here and attack this
one you go H six and it kind of feels
like
a um yeah it's it's a zuk Zong and then
you just pick up this Pawn on H5 and
he's out of
move yeah so where have we been tell me
how is the pull well we're ending it
right now and I have to say that in the
poll should elhan wear a hat
56% say yes he
should out of how many out of how many
is it important it is important it shows
the statistical power of the analysis 23
people
voted not strong enough at least you has
to be 30 now we consider that at just a
random chance so I I get to choose now I
don't think 56% I think is in the realm
of chance I don't think I think the
results are explainable by chance alone
because the results are explainable
because the results are expl explainable
by chance alone it's only a statistical
concept here it's just is it dis por hat
or is it a super big somero actually I
was wearing hat before denish you guys
have to we were roommates at Texas Tech
then he he started wearing hats I have
to say he started after me I was a
Pioneer
so people say you cannot take talk your
way out of it all
right so what's tomorrow's poll do I do
I have to keep my beers on or
not well it doesn't look like you'll
abide by it anyway so I don't know what
tomorrow no I I am the dude so the dude
that buys I'll wear a hat tomorrow okay
I lost I lost it but but I won't be here
to broadcast it I want to be doing a
concert okay on Thursday I'll be doing
another concert are you g to be here on
Tuesday no I'm gone this is the last one
oh my gosh so that's it that's it that's
it you Tracy are you going to be here
tomorrow yes okay so you're running his
class
tomorrow yes all right where yeah
tomorrow
okay okay only
tomorrow only tomorrow okay only
tomorrow so so many concerts for Ben
Simon what are we doing Ben Simon why so
many why so many hats
hey you know I just go where I needed he
just goes where he's needed you're not
needed here anymore we're going to miss
you I'm going to miss you yeah well it's
freezing in here so I'm not going to
miss
it
well okay fair enough Fair it
is fair enough it is and you guys are
here for hours I'm here for an
hour so okay before I freeze so much and
I need to wear my bear jackets I'm just
going to Bear Overcoat I'm just going to
say goodbye to everyone how was it Sarah
did you like it Sarah liked I hope you
guys also liked it too Ben Simon is
going to sign
off see you all I hope everyone had fun
and Ben Simon I'm going to wear a hat
tomorrow
unfortunately only tomorrow see
[Music]
you